[Music]  what's it like always known the truth  there's nothing this is all about it I  could just  and anyone is lying  I Know What You Did you're psycho  you live on the road right listen like  leave everything behind start fresh I  got rolls on my Fender oh I gotta keep  moving  holy holy  it wasn't an accident I think there's  been a murder foreign  I have been kind of a death magnet  I'm trying to figure out what happened  you watch too much Dateline I could tell  she was lying what is it it's a woman's  intuition no it's not like a tampon  commercial okay it's a real thing  [Music]  your choice  [Music]  I guess I'm not over the part where  you're a human lie detector yeah I know  it's uh it's crazy you ever gamble  because you can make a killing  nah  [Music]  thank you  thank you  [Music]